У
Країна зустрічає своїх героїв такі кадри
і щасливим поверненням фронту українське
телебачення показує Майже щодня
на телебаченні чіткість кінець серпня
українські солдати під іловайськом
виточені сепаратистів відчайдушна
кровопролитна битва серед учасників
військовий лікар Михайло Гулак і 400
добровольців уникнути смерті під
іловайськом вдалось лише третині
розповідає Гулак він і сам був поранений
ми зустрічаємось із Михайлом у Київській
лікарні через три тижні Після повернення
з війни у нас не
уявляєте собі спецпідрозділ міліції де
не війну на маршрутках Це була Газель у
якої навіть не було за кермом сидів Мій
друг Коля ленько я сидів поруч прикривав
з автомата і коли ми виїжджали
Дзержинськ у гальма не працювали
Іловайськ став найтрагічніші поразкою
українських бійців на сході за те що
живий Михайло дякує Богові а не своєї
зброї чи генералом
але на бойове завдання погодились
поїхати близько 90 бійців батальйону був
готовий зустріти ворога але Вибачте Не
було чим не було зброї для відбиття атак
а тим більше для контратак який бажано
було б йти контратаки північним були
просто призводять майже безперервних у
медики Михайло Гулак та Миколенко
рятували під іловайськом бійців
батальйону вони навіть робили
невідкладні операції в абсолютно не
придатних для цього умовах
перев'язувальний матеріал 60-х років
минулого століття відповідає жодним
стандартам решта поранених чекали зовні
поки домовляться про евакуацію
багато-хто Не дочекався
нас тут у бік батальйон насосі
батальйоном 2 штатні лікарі
не було автомобілів щоб вивозити
поранених ми не могли їх на носилках 20
км від лінії фронту
його жалієш кажеш Не хвилюйся тільки не
хвилюйся все буде добре а сам розумієш
що йому залишилося 10 хвилин в
і
нічого не поробиш це війна
війна Яка попри режим припинення вогню
триває на сході України війна з якою
багато солдатів дивом повертаються
живими в